medical police commerce and shiny in a
bad accident i said on commerce around
cheyenne both commerce and science
nine one one calls really showing the
panic among drivers after a horrific
crash happening over the weekend
and good evening to you i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez nine lives were
lost in that crash six of them children
and many in the community are still
struggling to come to terms with what
happened that includes the first
responders who are now shedding light on
the support they need on the job
victoria saha joining us live from north
las vegas with our top story
[Music]
denise and brian though the crash scene
is cleared and families are left to
grieve the aftermath of responding to
such a horrific crash is something
that's hard to move on from for our
first responders
so many people slide out the car get out
the car somebody's dead there's a lot of
people there inside
outside the car the frantic 9-1-1 calls
coming in from witnesses north las vegas
fire department station 50 was the first
to be paged out but had no idea the
situation they were about to face it was
this extremely traumatic event captain
dennis mclean with north las vegas fires
one of three supervisors for the
department's peer support group a
crucial resource needed after saturday's
call there was a lot of folks that
needed to talk he tells us the kitchen
table was filled with the 20
firefighters from saturday every one of
them needing to get something off their
chest for many it's going to be a once
in a career event with the amount of
tragedy that occurred at any one time
the peer support group always responds
when there's a critical incident
especially involving children diffusing
that formal meeting is so important and
that it allows
people to speak
and allows them to kind of start
letting go of the
emotional connection to what they see
the team consists of several other first
responders who have had to respond to
other traumatic events making it easier
to talk to someone who can relate
this group has resources to mental
health clinicians if the firefighters
want to continue talking to someone and
for those who responded on saturday i
was told that it made them reflect on
their home life a little more and hold
their children a little tighter
reporting live from north las vegas
tonight victoria saha live local now